- Mais voilà un an après, drtrtt
tant de libertés, j'apprends
jojojojourd'hui que tu viens
d'y perdre la tienne.
- Un film sous forme d'échanxxxx
réalisatrices, l'une vivanten F.
Le court métrage intitulé
"1er février" est une  l l l l .
Mo Mo, nom fictifsasasasa
protection, ne peut pas montrer
son visage en entrevue. Elle est
en
(slogans)
Au  s s s s sa vie,
la réalisatrice myanmaraise
populaire après le coup d'État.
On y  u u u u une femme timide,
qui s'épanouit malgré tout,
libre dans la foule
de mitititititititititititititi.
Mais la planète a depuis
détourné son attention.
Pourtant, la répress
la justice demeure arbitraire.
Le Myanmar est a
de la guerre civile.
Des groupes paramilitaires
résistent aux
réalisatrice qui avait découvert
une pleine liberté en voyageant
au Myanmar un an avant le coup
d'État, c'est l'impuissance
de vivre si loin.
LEÏLA M
co-réalisatrice "1er février"
- Bien, je suis consternée
par ce qt t t t t t t t t t t tr
d'expression et de création,
soitacacacacacacachant.
- Mo Mo, elle, veut encore
croire au changement,
ma
détermination. Elle a même
vécu une dépression.
sécurité, ce que j'espère, c'est
juste que Mo, un jour,
la même sécurité là où
elle habite, en fait.
- Le court mét
de ces deux femmes inspirantesu.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Singapour